[Music]
you know often i like to use this
segment for a bit of levity talking
about things that are perhaps not as
serious a bit more frivolous
especially on a friday but but sometimes
the news cycle forces me to wade into
deeper and more serious waters and deal
with true tragedies and outrages
that's what brings us to the rapper jim
jones not to be confused with the cult
leader jim jones with the we know the
poison kool-aid we have to drink a
different kind of kool-aid when we
encounter this story the kool-aid of
injustice
headlines from outlets like yahoo and
the independent tell us that jim jones
was recently the victim of racial
profiling at the gucci store in
manhattan
but that doesn't tell the whole story
not even close as it turns out jones was
with fellow rapper five mikes going to
various designer stores while filming a
video for their latest song going
shopping
now of course going shopping sounds like
the name of a song that the spice girls
would have made in 1997
but that's not the case jones and five
mikes are grown men who who happen to
love shopping and they wanted to make a
song about it and on this particular day
they visited louis vuitton burgdorf
goodman whatever that is
and um bergdorf is that a
is that a fancy clothing shop people
people intentionally wear clothing
bergdorf okay and a number of other
stores
while buying things and singing about
how much they love shopping
everything was fine until they made it
to gucci
and i will now let jones tell the story
in his own words and i warn you
this is very difficult to hear
we've been in gucci for about an hour
right and we're in gucci in the vip
for like two hours right since we came
in here having nobody came and showed us
no courtesy no amenities no nothing
period not even a drink of water
pause it there so that we can digest
what we've heard so far
uh jim jones and five mikes are in the
vip section of gucci
you may not have realized that stores
have vip sections but they do and that's
where the most victimized people end up
you might even call it the vip section
very important victims and jones and
five mikes are there literally dying of
thirst
they've been in the viv section for an
hour maybe even two hours without any
form of sustenance
they're on the verge of death when jim
jones finally pulls out his phone to
bravely document what might prove to be
his last words on earth
his tale of suffering only gets more
harrowing from there listen to this
actually speak to your manager
send me a black guy out here to start
telling me some [ __ ] so they got the
black guy racial profiling on black
people i had to speak to a manager
bigger than him everybody disappeared
ain't nobody come out [ __ ] i still ain't
getting i still ain't get no sparkling
water
i still ain't getting no champagne i
still ain't getting nothing
i didn't have a sales person inside of
my vip suite the whole time i was there
i had to keep screaming for vip people
to help me out now everybody don't know
where the real manager is you heard it's
it's time i'm tired of this we spending
all this money as entertainers inside
these stores they hire these black
people and these black people are more
racist than white people when they get
their job
inside of gucci all of a sudden you
stop playing with us bro
still haven't seen a manager yet
he's tired of this he's not gonna take
it anymore but won't someone speak up
for the entertainers in the vip section
at gucci if you feel like you're getting
the respect you deserve in life well
i've got a solution for you established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady and gain the
respect you deserve all you need is a
one square foot plot of land in scotland
in your title pack you'll receive at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land these title packs
are a fantastic gift and the best way to
surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends and boyfriends or even
family you could even get a couple pack
for you and your partner where you can
get adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles is having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com slash matt walsh or just click
the link below it's even worse than i
thought it's not that this man had been
deprived of regular water i mean what's
regular water gonna do for him anyway
regular water might be acceptable for
washing your hands or watering the grass
but you can't drink the stuff
jim jones required sparkling water and
yet none was provided to him in a timely
fashion
they couldn't even scrounge up any
champagne for the poor guy again you may
not have realized that getting served
champagne by customer service at a
retail store was even an option but it
is and i can tell you that i walked into
walgreens last week and i shot into the
cashier yes i have arrived please fetch
me some champagne and caviar and within
three minutes i was sitting at a table
by candlelight in the moisturizer
section whining and dining but then
again i'm white this is the kind of
treatment white people get everywhere we
go
jim jones is a black man at gucci
spending he says thirty thousand dollars
on clothes and shoes
he doesn't have any privilege at all
he is such a victim that even other
black people are racist against him the
race is against him by their failure to
submissively serve his every whim in
need now you might say that from the
sound of it if anything he is racist
against them but you only say that
because you are also racist against jim
jones you do not have his lived
experience
like the lived experience of spending 30
grand on designer clothing in one day
something that only the most oppressed
among us are able to do
fortunately thank god uh jones and five
mikes
did survive this experience um somehow
later jones posted an update to social
media he wrote quote
gucci really some suckers and for those
looking from the outside saying this is
some rich privilege it's really not it's
about treating people with respect no
matter the race or what you may think
you know about a person and for people
saying that spending money foolishly you
never know what a person been through so
you should never worry about what a
person does with his
very well put
it's none of your business how much
money he spends
which is why he posted a video to
instagram telling everyone how much
money he spent
you simply cannot know what this man has
been through until he complains about it
publicly which he does a lot apparently
and to think that jones would be put
through this ordeal during black history
month no less
it's the sort of thing that fills you
with disgust and rage down to the pit of
your being
you know when i was in that third world
country last week and i i thought those
people were suffering
but i guarantee none of them here's what
i can tell you for sure none of them
have ever received poor customer service
at gucci
their lives are blessed beyond measure
in comparison to jim jones and his
friend five mikes
in fact speaking of his friend from what
i hear they were so deprived and
suffered such deprivation at gucci
that by the time they left five mikes
was only three mikes
that was bad i'm sorry about that one
i know there's nothing i can do right
now uh to heal this wrong that jim jones
has suffered but but i'll i'll be doing
my part at least by boycotting gucci
stores from here on out in fact i've
been boycotting gucci my whole life in
preparation for this moment i have
literally never purchased a single gucci
item
and i tell you right now i promise you i
never will
it's the least i can do
and i can also say to gucci and all of
its employees with righteous flirt fury
you scoundrels are cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content